Hey, this is Presh Talwalkar.
A child spent $100 to get
100 toy animals.
The child bought at least one cat,
one fish,
and one bird,
and did not buy
any other toys.
If a cat costs $10,
a fish costs $3,
and a bird costs 50 cents,
how many of each toy did the child buy?
Can you figure it out?
Give this problem a try,
and when you're ready,
keep watching the
video for the solution.
Since the child bought 100 toys in total,
we know the number of cats plus the
number of fish
plus the number of birds is equal to 100.
Furthermore, the child spent $100
in total, and we know the cost
of each toy.
This leads to the equation
that 10 times
the number of cats plus 3 times the
number of fish plus .5 times the
number of birds is equal to 100.
Let's simplify these equations.
From the first equation,
we'll solve for the
number of birds.
This will be: the number of birds is
equal to 100
minus the number of cats
minus the number of fish.
We can substitute that
into the second equation.
We'll now simplify this
and then we'll
simplify it further.
We end up that 19
times the number of cats
plus 5 times
the number of fish is equal to 100.
Let's continue from this equation.
We'll solve for the number of fish.
We have: the number of fish
is equal to 20 minus the
number of cats times
19 over 5.
This will be the key equation
to deduce the answer.
The variable "cats" is being multiplied
by 19 over 5.
Now we need the number of fish
to be a whole number,
and we know that
the number of cats
is also a whole number.
This means the number of cats has to be
a multiple of 5 so that the number of
fish is a whole number.
Furthermore, we need the number of fish
to be a number that's greater than 0.
We're taking 20 minus
the number of cats
times 19 over 5.
So we can figure out
that the number of cats
has to be less than
100 over 19,
or approximately 5.26,
so that the
number of fish is greater
than 0.
So we need a multiple of five
that's less than
about 5.26,
and we know that
the number of cats
is also greater than zero.
So what number is a
multiple of 5
that's greater than 0
but less than 5.26?
There's only one possibility,
which is that the number of cats is
equal to five.
So we've uniquely solved for
the number of cats,
and we can substitute
that value to get that the number of
fish has to equal 1.
We now need to figure out
the number of birds,
but we know the total number of animals is
equal to 100.
So we can then say
that the number of birds
is equal to 94,
and this is the unique solution
to this problem.
Did you figure it out?
Thanks for watching this video.
Please subscribe to my channel.
I make videos on math and game theory.
You can catch me on my blog,
"Mind Your Decisions",
which you can follow on
Facebook, Google+, and Patreon.
You can catch me on social media:
@preshtalwalkar,
and if you like this video,
please check out my books.
There are links
in the video description.